hi there Steve Kaufman here today was a
heavy Korean learning day I am preparing
for my trip I'm going to Boston tomorrow
to the American Conference of teachers
of foreign languages convention there
and so I went through a lot of Korean
texts looking words up in the dictionary
so that there socked in as saved links
on my iPad and my iPhone so that I can
study them offline I went through
basically just saving the blue words now
I've got a bunch of yellow words I'm
going to read through the text while I'm
on the airplane and I got my handy
Korean history textbook with the Chinese
characters but today I want a ramble a
bit because I want to refer to there's
reference here in the comments to a blog
posed by a person who essentially
attacked all the principles of input
based learning stephen krashen and so
forth so I want to ramble a bit in
response to this blog post since I'm
going to Boston I'm gonna have a blast
there with all these teachers and people
who are interested in languages and I am
a supported receiving crash who's gonna
be there by the way I'm looking forward
to meeting him there but here is what
this person had to say this person's
name is John Franco Conde a co-author of
the language teacher toolkit winner of
the 2015 best resource contributor award
blah blah blah and he is a PhD in
applied linguistics MA in teaching to
the foreign language and Maine
literature English Center and Sorenson
his point is that there are five mixed
messages which have severely damaged
modern language education and he
basically blames stephen krashen and the
first of these is the idea that we
shouldn't teach grammar because we
should learn like children and children
learn subconsciously well it's an
oversimplification of course we don't
learn like children because we have our
life experience and our vocabulary in
our own language which the children
don't have but there are many things
that the children do that we can imitate
and that is exposing ourselves to a lot
of
content and it doesn't it isn't that we
shouldn't teach any grammar but I I
believe that we shouldn't expect that
because we teach grammar people are
gonna get it right a lot of grammar is
very immune to explanation correctness
over the zone I know this all the time
we see we see who people who can't get
the third person singular the present
tense right after 10 or 15 years of
grammar instruction he do he go she go
I always mentioned Chinese people who
after 10 15 years or longer are still
saying my husband she it just takes a
while for these things to sink in and
the more sort of framework reference
framework we have the more the grammar
instruction is relevant so I think that
number one point crashing emphasizes
meaningful input as a major contributor
to language acquisition
I think crashing is right and our friend
John Franco is wrong the second point he
says is don't use the first language in
the classroom I don't need to go through
all of it but I agree with you I think
where necessary use the first language
in the classroom if you're teaching
Spanish person doesn't understand what
you're saying use some English stuff
doesn't even answer in English and also
dictionaries I always prefer a bilingual
dictionary as opposed to one that's the
monolingual dictionary where the
dictionary definition contains a lot of
words that again I don't understand so
that's true I'll go for that
the third point he says is that a myth
that's damaging right and his point is
that somehow it's since the seventies
since learner based instruction and
crashing that everything has gone to
hell well I studied language in the
language early in the 50s people didn't
learn in Montreal all the people in
English school system didn't learn to
speak French any more than they do now
and what's more language instruction is
still heavily grammar focused that
hasn't changed us the most common
complaint that I get from people at link
or on my youtube channel is so but then
he says another myth era is that it's
not important for students to understand
all they read or hear well there's all
kinds of research
and I mentioned the professor Robert
Bjork who points out that we need we
shouldn't try and force ourselves to
understand something we should we should
interleave we should do a little bit of
this a little bit of that and go back to
the other and if we learn and forget
learn and forget we're gonna learn
better than if we try to force ourselves
to learn something to master it as he
says to master 90 95 percent of it
I think the main thing is to do things
that you find interesting stimulating
and and move on as long as you're
motivated to try and understand a bit
more stay with it
but once you find it boring or
uninteresting move on to something else
so it's not necessary he says you have
to understand 99.5% of the text before
I'm moving on I don't believe that but I
can see that in a classroom context that
might be something to strive for then he
says another myth is that teachers must
be tolerant of mistakes I think the main
thing again is to get people
communicating some mistakes are not
gonna correct themselves no matter how
much you correct people I have done it
you know tutoring people via Skype you
correct them they come right back with
them same mistake same with me I make a
mistake tutor corrects me sends it you
know on my link conversation report and
then the same mistake is corrected in
the following conversation it takes a
long time and the bulk of these mistakes
we correct them ourselves after enough
exposure so teachers not necessarily be
tolerant of mistakes but it's not a big
deal to make mistakes so that's also and
he says that if we if the teachers
tolerate mistakes the mistakes will be
fossilized will be ingrained in the
learner but what does that mean if the
bulk of what the learner is doing is
listening and reading if I'm listening
to stuff if I'm reading how am I in
graining errors if you don't demand of
me that I produce the language all the
time which i think is unnecessary at an
early stage
I'm not going to ingrain any errors but
I might just be enjoying what I'm
listening to and reading and the final
one he says is that another myth is of
pronunciation is not important it's only
important to be understood well again
it's like this big issue of grammar it's
not
no grammar but is how much emphasis to
put our driver so how much emphasis
should you put on pronunciation should
you make people self-conscious about
their pronunciation particularly early
on I find that it takes a long time for
me to get used to the intonation of the
language the pronunciation and sometimes
some things that I don't notice in the
pronunciation at an early stage I start
to notice later on so when I can hear
things better and I notice things better
I believe I have a better chance of
pronouncing them better
so again if the teacher is forcing
people to speak in the classroom wants
them to speak correctly he's irritated
by their mistakes he's irritated by
their poor pronunciation maybe that's an
issue but if you can get people to learn
and hear again his assumption is that
kids won't read kids won't just listen
but my grandchildren who went to French
immersion they had to read on history
and chemistry and physics and math in
French and they did it so you can get
kids to do that and maybe instead of
questioning them on every detail and
making sure they correctly answer
questions about what happened in a
particular bit of reading that they did
if you simply said again if they're
using link make sure they create links
on every page or they're looking words
up but also write a bit about your
impression of what you read to show the
derivative essentially and use some of
the words that you learned and we won't
mark you down for grammar mistakes and
we won't won't mark you down for missing
pressures about what happened in the
story we just want you to use the
language and show that you listen and
read and you enjoyed it and maybe your
interpretation is different than the you
know call it the correct interpretation
but you enjoyed that engagement with the
language enough so in other words I
think that it all boils down to what
this lady who I hope I will see in
Boston and whom I met in San Diego the
last time I attended one of these
conferences dr. Mary Ann Lyman Hagar who
at that time
the head of the language acquisition
Resource Center at Sandia San Diego
State University and who said there are
only three things that mattered in
language learning the attitude of the
learner the time spent with the language
and developing the ability to notice and
I think that developing the ability to
notice comes from spending the time
comes from having the right attitude and
those are the only thing that only
things that matter so essentially I
reject this criticism of crashing
however I do recognize that those people
who like to go at language learning in
some other way with an emphasis on Anki
or an emphasis on grammar if that's what
they enjoy doing if that's what gets
them to spend time with the language if
that's what turns their crank therefore
gives them a positive attitude by all
means go for it anyway I'm going for it
I'm going to Boston tomorrow morning and
bye for now